[Musique]
il brise bonjour bonjour bonjour à tous
bonjour à tous les maris noir alors vous
menez à liszt le marin en avant vous
avez obtenu 38% des suffrages exprimés
lors du premier tour soit environ 1300
27 votants ce qui représente seulement
33 voix du plus que josé mirande qui est
arrivé en deuxième position
comment à 1000 analysez vous ce premier
tour je trouve que c'est très bien pour
un tour où on avait beaucoup de
candidats sur le bas rhin on va dire
tous contre moi
tout le monde le reconnaît que nous
soyons deuxième tour est en tête de ce
premier tour
c'est une très bonne chose et j'en
profite justement pour remercier tous
ceux qui ont porté leur suffrage au nom
pour la liste le marais en avant et puis
on invite tous ceux qui n'ont pas été
votées à venir voter alors d'une façon
ou d'une autre mais en tout cas de faire
attention gestes barrières etc
nous travaillons
avec les uns et les autres sur le
terrain justement pour continuer à
expliquer notre programme pour
poursuivre aussi un ce travail de
terrain que nous faisons depuis très
longtemps et dire ben que j'entends je
vois j'ai travaillé j'ai été sur le
terrain et qu'il ya des choses
effectivement qui doivent bouger on va
on va on va parler du terrain comment
vous le pratiquez justement avec cette
pandémie
l'aco vide pour vous jouer sur ce
premier tour a eu un impact sur ce
premier tour oui bien sûr enfin cesser
de notoriété on va dire nationale bien
évidemment que ça ça a eu un impact
c'était quelque chose de nouveau une
compréhension une incompréhension une
grande crainte
je dirais que je comprends ceux qui ne
sont pas venus parce que le danger était
bien là et c'est pour ça aussi que nous
avons décidé pour ce deuxième tour en
tout cas pour le moment de ne pas faire
de meeting très bien vous avez discuté
avec les autres listes ceux qui ne
lisent lise liste qui ne sont pas ou ne
sont pas qualifiés pour le deuxième tour
est ce qu'il ya des soutiens qui
apparaissent inévitables alors bien sûr
non il ya des soutiens m'a dit il ya des
soutiens mais vous savez les têtes de
liste ont donné leur avis que je
respecte
en tout cas pour deux d'entre elles de
ne pas donner de consigne de vote
ce que je respecte parfaitement
maintenant il y à des tests de lister
une tête de liste ne va pas non plus
sans autres colistiers et autres
personnes autour donc de me dire qu'il
ya des têtes de listes qui n'ont pas
donné d'avis mais qui a des soutiens pas
fait il ya des soutiens qui m'a fait en
fait des soutiens soutien reste un
soutien ya jamais de soutien en bas fait
enfin en tout cas c'est pas en bataille
contre le bulletin il est mis et il est
mis pour d'autres indices s'étaient pas
fait il ya des gens qui appellent à
voter pour vous oui bien sûr il ya des
personnes aussi qui viennent à nos
réunions qui sont avec nous vraiment
vous savez tout le monde au marin sait à
quel point je ne suis pas quelqu'un de
sectaire quelqu'un qui fasse de
différences entre les uns et les autres
à chaque fois que j'ai eu à travailler
j'ai travaillé pour tous et avec tous et
dans mon quotidien je suis avec tout le
monde
donc aujourd'hui ça ne pose aucun
problème d'écouter ce que disent les
autres aussi de faire évoluer notre
projet et prendre en compte d'autres
choses mais il n'empêche que notre liste
et représentait exactement sous le même
format
qu'est ce que ça a changé cette pandémie
vous disiez que vous ne faites plus de
neil pas fuir de meetings pour l'instant
la fin donc qu'est ce que ça a changé
dans votre voix là dans votre campagne
du deuxième tour
vous savez nous étions déjà sur les
terrains un mois particulièrement depuis
de nombreuses années aller chez les uns
et les autres donc
là dessus ça ne change pas trop
maintenant peut-être que avoir un petit
peu plus de support à renaître être
beaucoup plus sur les réseaux j'avoue
que ce n'était pas mon fort
personnellement autour de moi oui est
donc bien là aussi on apprend aussi
certaines nouvelles techniques et je
trouve ça très bien
bien évidemment nous sommes conscients
que beaucoup n'ont pas non plus une
stagnation facebook etc et que la
proximité comme toujours reste notre fer
de lance notre bâton de pèlerin dernière
question quel sera votre grand chantier
quel sera le prix la première action que
vous mettrez en place si vous êtes élu
écoutez ce n'est pas créée l'action la
première action que je mettrai en place
et bien évidemment sur quoi je vais
continuer à travailler pour que nous
puissions avoir ce cadre de vie tant
attendu tant espéré de tous c'est
vraiment faire non plus le lien n'est le
liant entre toutes ces activités un
cadre de vie qui comprend bien
évidemment l'intergénérationnel les
associations le sport la culture et
c'est bien évidemment nos réseaux
routiers parce que c'est très important
et puis ne pas laisser tomber non plus
ce développement économique quoi qu'on
dise qui est reconnue à l'international
et là je suis en train de travailler
avec les équipes
grâce à ce programme odyssea sur lequel
nous travaillons depuis de longues
années maintenant à mettre en place ce
territoire 0 chômage et où nous allons
accompagner un bon nombre de femmes qui
sont au chômage de longue durée c'est
l'un défend programme en tout cas le
cadre de vie pour tous yvonne truite je
vous remercie
merci à vous et merci à tous les marées
noires